It's hard to get to space
As much as we all wish there were an easy,
and affordable way to see our planet
floating in the dark
Right now, the only way is to become
an astronaut or a billionare
But there is a concept
that might make it possible
-while serving as the starting point
for the exploration of the universe-
The space elevator
How exactly does it work?
To understand how a space elevator
will get us into space
We must first understand
what an orbit is
Being in orbit basically means
falling towards something,
but moving fast enough to miss
If you throw a ball on earth
it makes an arch through the air,
and then hits the ground
In space, gravity makes you move
much the same way,
but if you move sideways fast enough
the curvature of the earth makes the ground
fall away beneath you
as fast as gravity pulls you towards it
So, to enter Earth's orbit
rockets have to go up
and sideways fast
By contrast, a space elevator
taps into energy from Earth's rotation
to get the cargo going fast
Imagine a child spinning a toy on a rope
with an ant on the child's hand
As the ant climbs out along the rope
it starts to move faster and faster
as it ascends
Compared to rockets,
with cargo launched on an elevator
you only need to provide
the energy to go up
Fast sideways movement comes free
with the Earth's rotation
But the space elevator would without a doubt
be the single largest and most expensive
structure ever built by humans
So, is it worth it?
It all comes down to costs
Rockets burn a huge amount of rocket fuel
just to get a small
amount of cargo into space
At current prices, it costs about $20,000
to put one kilogram of payload into space
that's $1.3 million dollars
for the average human
$40 million dollars for your car
billions for
an international space station
This immense cost is one of the major
limitations of human spaceflight
Even with advancing technology,
this cost isn't likely to be comparable with the
price of an airline ticket anytime soon
A space elevator would solve this problem
After construction,
a space elevator is projected to reduce the cost
one hundredfold to $200 per kilogram
If an inexpensive space elevator
costs 20 billion dollars,
then we'll recoup our losses
after launching only one million tons
Close to the weight
of two international space stations
So what would a space elevator look like
in real life?
A space elevator has four major components:
the tether, anchor, counterweight
and climber
The elevator part of the space elevator
is the tether and the climber
It extends from the surface of the Earth to space
The climber is like a conventional
elevator carriage
A chamber that works its way
up and down the tether
At the base would be an anchor
pinning the tether to the Earth
along with a port for climbers
At the top is the counterweight
which holds up the tether
The tether is held tight like a rope
and supported from above
by the tension from the counterweight
Located higher than 36,000 kilometers
above the Earth's surface
At the counterweight
could be a space station,
a launching point for all missions
from the spaceport elevator
But can we actually build one?
It's hard to say
The biggest challenge is the tether
It needs to be light, affordable
and more stable than any material
we can produce right now
There are promising materials
like graphene and diamond nanothreads,
but even they may not be strong enough
And aside from being incredibly strong,
the tether would also have to withstand
atmospheric corrosion, radiation
and micrometeorite and debris impacts
Additionally, it takes several days
to climb the elevator
How do we power the climber?
It requires a lot of energy to go up
Do we need a nuclear reactor
on our elevator carriage?
Or do we beam it power from the ground
with a super powered laser?
And where do we get the raw materials
for a 36,000-kilometer-long tether?
Do we make it on Earth
and launch it into space?
Or do we make it in space
and lower it down to the Earth?
Could asteroid mining be the answer?
Put simply, there are still some major
technological hurdles to overcome
And a space elevator is not without risk
Should the tether break,
it would collapse in spectacular style
If it breaks near the anchor
the force exerted by the counterweight
will cause the entire elevator to rise up
ascending into space
Should it break near the counterweight
the tether will fall,
wrapping around the world
and whipping the end off
The resulting debris in orbit could pose
serious problems to future spaceflight
If we build a space elevator on Earth,
we have to do it right the first time
For these reasons some experts
have proposed first building
a space elevator on the Moon
The Moon's gravity
is much weaker than the Earth's
so a flimsier but existing material
like kevlar
could serve as a tether
Even with all these challenges,
the payoff of having a working
space elevator would be immense
It might be the first step to truly becoming
a space-faring civilization
Maybe we will never build
a space elevator,
but in trying to do so
we might learn an awful lot
And when it comes
to the exploration of the universe,
there can't be too many dreams
of a glorious future